it's rare enough in a film series goes
all the way to a fifth installment it's
even more rare when the fifth one is
absolutely positively flat-out the so
Fast Five yes fast in the Furious Five
wow that's a lot of Fast and Furious
movies this one is directed by Justin
land who directed three four and now
five I've seen one four and five I have
yet to see two and three
I enjoy women for their fun movies you
know I enjoy them and I didn't really
expect much of two and three I'll check
them out someday so this film begins
where the fourth one left off with them
busting Vin Diesel out of jail and it
just starts right off the bat they're
trying to pull another job for the
basically trying to rob money from the
biggest criminal in all of Brazil and of
course we got fast cars lots of action
girls and fast cars now let me just
start by saying that I love this movie
so here's the deal this movie has one
thing to do entertain you to death with
fun chases involving cars fight scenes
action scenes good locations and oh my
word it does it so well this film knows
exactly what it is just a really fun
testosterone-fueled action movie and I'm
going to be honest this is one of the
best action films I have ever seen and
simply from an action perspective this
film is absolutely astounding it is by
far in my opinion the best Fast &
Furious movie I mean I haven't seen two
and three I am completely blown away by
how much I enjoyed this movie the
biggest strength this movie is it's fun
the characters are all fun together the
characters the way they interact their
banter the the witty lines and
everything
all just so entertaining and fun I saw
this with a huge audience and I can't
even count how many times the fella
listed a round of applause from the
audience you know action is good we're
what I have it's like oh my gosh and
you're just like laughing I mean you're
not laughing at it you're just like wow
that was intense
as a guy this is this is the guy movie I
mean this this film knows exactly what
it's supposed to be and it doesn't ever
try to be anything else and it succeeds
so so well it doing what it's supposed
to I was like one the rock and vin
diesel fight I am going to poop
everywhere and I did figuratively
it was awesome
see I could find a lot of problems with
it's going to be okay because the action
some of it is preposterous I mean no
never going to happen everyone would die
you know just it just never going to
happen if I view this film like some
tightwad like that then I'd hate it you
have to understand what a film is going
for all it's trying to be as a fun
fast-paced action film and holy crap
does it ever succeed at that by far the
best action film of the year so far from
an action perspective I have not been
this glued to the screen since inception
car races yes heists yes fight scenes
yes running chases yes rooftop parkour
esque chases yes and the director Justin
Lin my goodness he knows how to film
action he's not zooming in on the
people's pupils and shaking up the
camera do you can't tell what's going on
everything you can see legit stunts
happening from wide angles where you can
see the whole thing take place in one
shot and it's well edited and it looks
real and the actors do a lot of their
own stunts I'm so happy when old
fashioned action scenes are on the
screen it's just it there's so much
better than some of the stuff that's out
nowadays you know and I just wish more
directors knew that and this one this
guy Justin Linea understands the action
scenes very good job my friend if you're
a fan of The Fast and Furious films more
than likely this will
we be one of your favorites if not your
favorite if you like action movies on my
word what are you doing see it if I do
say so myself
Vin Diesel is actually a pretty good
actor Paul Walker is good in the film
for what he needs to be he fits well in
this universe of fast and furious he is
a little bit bland I've seen him in
another performance just like eight
below where I thought he did a nice job
Dwayne Johnson is just he's always
likable you know I mean he's a very
likable actor and he's a good actor my
word he is huge in this movie I mean guy
is tone I was just watched like he can't
even walk like with his arms at his side
his giant muscles and everything like
push them out I mean like the guy is
huge it seems like Vin Diesel bulked up
this movie took I'm good at the fight
the rocks I'm gonna have to bulk up
considerably the villain role is you
know he's just not so much of a villain
as he could be he's very cliched as a
male an evil drug dealer guy you don't
like him I have not seen a movie so
manly and just absolutely testosterone
fueled nos injected beastliness in a
very long time I mean it definitely
check out Fast Five it's one of my
favorite action movies I've seen in
recent times I'm gonna give it three and
a half out of four stars definitely
check it out when you get a chance my
word oh my
you